Bienvenidos a esta edición de la
entrevista de France 24 nos acompaña Eva
Olson ella es física y es profesora de
la universidad tecnológica de chambers
también miembro de la Real Academia
sueca de ciencias y parte del comité de
Selección del premio Nobel de física
precisamente de ese galardón vamos a
hablar otorgado este 2022 a John and
closer aspect y Anthony gerson Pioneros
en la información cuántica muy buenos
días y gracias por estar con nosotros
doctora Olson lo primero que quiero
preguntarles Cómo se deciden los premios
Nobel usted más que nadie lo sabe cómo
son elegidos Cómo se toma esta decisión
es fácil es difícil
no es difícil en realidad es un trabajo
fascinante todo se basa en las
nominaciones a finales de enero de cada
año hay un plazo para presentar las
postulaciones para los temas para los
premios Nobel y también para las
personas que merecen el premio
Y luego el comité revisa todo el
material hacemos casi como un trabajo de
detectives porque tenemos que
asegurarnos dependiendo del tema de
quien realmente hizo el trabajo original
que llegó al descubrimiento o a la
invención es mucho trabajo pero es
realmente fascinante
también es fascinante hablar de esto
aquí en las noticias la física es
precisamente uno de los campos en los
que menos mujeres han recibido el premio
Nobel y también quería preguntarle cómo
se explica esto cree que debería O
podría hacerse algo al respecto
en primer lugar el premio Nobel tiene
que ver principalmente con el tema así
que se trata fundamentalmente del tema y
luego una vez que decidimos qué tema Es
realmente el más importante el tema que
realmente Debería ser premiado entonces
empezamos a considerar a las personas
y también debemos recordar que
tradicionalmente ha habido muchos
hombres en el campo de la física Pero
esto está cambiando con el tiempo la
mayoría de las veces se necesita tiempo
antes de que haya un premio Nobel esto
significa que estamos considerando un
trabajo que a menudo se realizó hace
muchos años y en ese entonces había más
hombres en comparación con las mujeres
en la física
pero también recuerden Premio Nobel en
2018 fue para Donna streetland y también
en 2020 tuvimos a Andrea que es así que
las cosas están cambiando puede que la
base vaya más despacio de lo que
quisiéramos pero las cosas están
cambiando y también Estamos buscando
Cómo asegurarnos de que reconozcamos el
trabajo de toda la gente no solo de las
mujeres sino también de otros países
diferentes
este año el premio fue para los
científicos que llevaron la física
cuántica al terreno de la física
experimental y demostraron que la
naturaleza también responde a la física
cuántica Cómo cambia y revoluciona esto
nuestra forma de ver el mundo
[Aplausos]
la mecánica cuántica describe algo que
ocurre en dimensiones muy pequeñas y
resulta que ahora que la teoría está
demostrando ser correcta resulta que el
mundo a pequeña Escala se comporta De
manera diferente en comparación con lo
que normalmente experimentamos usando
nuestros sentidos como nuestros ojos y
también las mediciones normales
que he citado en realidad hizo
predicciones y sociencia mientras se
desarrollaba el debate hizo predicciones
que les permitieron a los laureados
hacer las mediciones experimentales y
luego poder demostrar en este caso que
la mecánica cuántica es una descripción
correcta Entonces se lanzó este extraño
comportamiento del entrelazamiento
descripción
una de las cosas que demostraron es que
dos partículas pueden estar entrelazadas
y que algo que le ocurre a una afecta lo
que le ocurre a la otra sin necesidad de
que haya una señal entre ambas algo que
de hecho al propio Einstein le parecía
fantasmagórico como se entrelazan Qué
significa eso
se trata de dos partículas que se
comportan como una unidad provienen del
mismo origen y están entrelazadas y
luego cuando se separan Todavía siguen
estando relacionadas
eso significa que cuando se mide en una
partícula se conoce el estado de la otra
y eso ocurre a distancias muy largas
esto es el núcleo del entrelazamiento
esa relación que existe sin importar la
distancia entre las dos partículas
Cómo se aplica esto en nuestras vidas
creo que es una pregunta que todos nos
hacemos cuando empezamos a oír hablar de
la mecánica
cuántications
aquí es cuando llegamos a las
aplicaciones y aquí están viendo donde
especialmente a tu sillinger entra
entonces jean-clauser realizaba
experimentos para verificar si la
mecánica cuántica era una teoría
verdadera dando una descripción completa
y el trabajo Fue continuado por aspect
para el refinamiento de las mediciones
desarrolló la forma en que podemos
trabajar y controlar el estado del
entrelazamiento Y eso está abriendo
posibilidades para aplicaciones en el
futuro luego tenemos la criptografía que
es una forma segura de transferir
información y también tenemos la
computación cuántica y de hecho su
trabajo también nos está ayudando a
mejorar la tecnología de detección Pero
esto es lo que vemos hoy no sabemos lo
que pasará dentro de 10 años podemos
tener una aplicación completamente nueva
de este fenómeno y por eso es tan
importante que involucremos a los
jóvenes para que aprendan sobre el
fenómeno y que luego se les ocurran
nuevas aplicaciones en las que aún no
hemos pensado
application
algo que definitivamente aprendemos con
los premios noveles que nunca sabemos
Dónde están los límites del conocimiento
simplemente lo seguimos expandiendo
precisamente quería preguntarle por esas
computadoras cuánticas de las que
hablaba por qué son más potentes que las
que tenemos hoy en día cómo es posible
para ser sincera yo misma estoy
aprendiendo sobre el campo de las
computadoras cuánticas lo que sé es que
permiten la computación cuántica está en
una fase muy temprana por lo que todavía
estamos hablando de una red muy pequeña
de cubits que son la base de una
computadora cuántica son ruidos de
complex
[Música]
Así que probemos que las posibles
computadoras cuánticas del futuro pueden
realizar operaciones muy complejas que
hoy realizan en las computadoras
tradicionales existentes pero aún no
estamos ahí lo que pasa es que ese no es
mi campo y no conozco los detalles pero
lo fascinante es que se podrán predecir
y realizar tantas operaciones que no se
pueden entender del todo por ejemplo los
procesos de catálisis y cómo se puede
optimizar la catálisis para diferentes
aplicaciones pero está mucho más allá de
lo que podemos hacer hoy y aún no
sabemos lo que alcanzaremos en un futuro
una de las cosas que algunos de mis
compañeros querían preguntar es que
ahora mismo somos capaces de
teletransportar más o menos información
de una partícula a otra a través de
cientos de kilómetros eso significa que
en el futuro podemos teletransportar
masa o incluso teletransportarnos a
nosotros mismos
lamentablemente no voy a explicarlo así
lo que tenemos hoy es una teoría y una
comprensión pero no se trata de
transportar más agua o átomos sino de
conseguir transferir información
No ahora Una vez que se tiene la
información transferida entonces se
puede utilizar para construir algo que
es idéntico a lo que había en el otro
extremo Por así decirlo pero hoy en día
no se trata de transportar masa no pases
esperemos que alguien que nos escuche
siga soñando y ya veremos qué pasa en
los próximos años también quería
preguntarle el premio Nobel de física es
uno de los que más llama la atención y
es algo que realmente cautiva a la gente
Aunque quizás sea uno de los más
difíciles de entender cómo es que la
gente se siente tan atraída por la
física
solo puedo responder por mí misma es
porque la física describe el mundo en el
que vivimos por lo tanto obtenemos la
comprensión básica de los fenómenos que
actúan sobre nosotros y también
obtenemos conocimientos sobre cómo
optimizar los rendimientos todo consiste
en entender el mundo en el que vivimos y
cuando lo hacemos va más allá de nuestra
vida en la tierra en realidad también se
extiende al espacio y luego entran una
escala muy pequeña como la que tuvimos
en este caso en el que hablamos de
fotones y electrones Así que desde mi
punto de vista una cosa es que
entendemos cada vez más el mundo que nos
rodea y la otra es que el mundo es
fantástico creo que eso es lo
fundamental por amor
hablaba usted de las computadoras
cuánticas pero en términos de
información algunas de las personas que
recibieron el premio han sido llamadas
los padres de la información en la
mecánica cuántica Cómo se está
revolucionando el mundo de la
información de la comunicación a través
de la mecánica cuántica
la mecánica cuántica está haciendo
predicciones Y eso nos informa sobre los
mecanismos que podemos utilizar por
ejemplo como la criptografía en cuanto a
las aplicaciones para Incluso si
obtenemos esas predicciones no significa
que simplemente salgamos de laboratorio
y hagamos el trabajo
todavía tenemos que desarrollar
condiciones experimentales para poder
hacer las mediciones Así que creo que de
lo que estamos hablando es de nuevos
conocimientos que nos permitan dar el
siguiente paso no estoy segura de estar
respondiendo su pregunta creo que aquí
Necesito ayuda
nuestra pregunta y además siempre es muy
interesante hablar y discutir sobre
estas cosas con las personas que están
más familiarizadas con el tema quería
agradecerle que está aquí con nosotros y
que nos explique cosas tan complicadas
de forma que todos podamos entenderlas
Muchas gracias Fue un placer hablar con
usted muchas gracias y hasta aquí
estamos con la entrevista de France 24
por favor sigan con nosotros en France
24 y France 24.com
[Música]